Donc la vérité centrale de la lettre aux Philippiens, elle se trouve au chapitre 3.
Donc là, on voit comment le chapitre 4 commence avec cette expression, c'est pourquoi Paul, il est en train de conduire son enseignement.
Et je vous rappelle, les lettres de Paul, ce sont les repères que nous avons pour apprendre à faire des serments,
car ces lettres étaient comme des serments écrits, comme des prédications écrites, où il présentait les vérités bibliques,
il expliquait la doctrine ou les vérités bibliques et il va toujours vers la fin de la lettre porter quelques applications.
Donc en vue de ces vérités glorieuses, voici comment vous devez vivre.
Et donc on a cette conscience qu'à partir du moment où Dieu dans sa grâce nous expose à la connaissance
et à la compréhension de certaines vérités, au même instant nous devenons rédévables devant Dieu,
nous allons rendre compte devant Dieu, de marcher à la hauteur de ce qu'on a appris.
Et donc vers la fin de la lettre, l'apôtre Paul au chapitre 4 commence à appliquer cette vérité centrale.
Donc la vérité centrale est à propos de la joie chrétienne,
Philippiens est appelé la lettre de la joie,
et c'est un rappel, comme on fait par plusieurs répétitions ces rappels.
La réalité c'est que chrétien et tristesse c'est une contradiction.
Et l'une des plus grandes raisons pour laquelle certains chrétiens vivent en contradiction,
parfois c'est car ils ne sont pas vraiment convertis,
mais très souvent c'est plutôt le fait qu'ils ne sont pas en phase avec leur nouvelle nature.
Ils semblent avoir oublié ou ne pas avoir fait attention
que le mieux des dieux a été déjà reçu lorsqu'ils ont connu l'excellence du Christ,
lorsqu'ils ont compris qu'ils sont délivrés de l'enfer
et que leur futur envers la gloire est assuré,
et qu'il prend dans ses pèlerinages,
sa plus grande joie c'est son intimité, sa conformité avec Christ.
Que ce soit par la gratitude développée par les bénédictions temporelles des dieux,
que ce soit par les souffrances qui nous poussent à nous sanctifier,
tout concourt à la progression dans la conformité du chrétien
avec l'objet suprême de son amour,
les caractères des dieux en qui nous avons tout notre plaisir.
Et parfois les chrétiens distraits,
s'accrochent à cette vie éphémère
et essayent de transmettre leur attente et joie
envers des choses que Dieu n'a jamais promis qu'il allait nous donner
de manière assurée dans cette vie.
Ils oublient ce qu'ils ont déjà un Christ.
La lettre des Philippiens, elle est...
On n'a pas la capacité de dévier, elle est incontournable
comme une attestation
que les sommets de la joie chrétienne
peuvent être retrouvés dans les pires circonstances de cette vie.
Car l'apôtre Paul écrit la lettre de la joie
en étant emprisonné
dans des circonstances vraiment très misérables.
Et c'est dès là
que l'apôtre Paul nous enseigne
à comment se réjouir
dans la plénitude
et comment il a la capacité d'exhorter
tous les chrétiens à se réjouir
en circonstances beaucoup plus favorables
que la sienne.
Et donc la lettre des Philippiens
a
les fondements suprêmes de la joie
au chapitre 3, les versets 7 et 8
qui nous montrent
que même si Paul était quelque part très réussi
dans sa vie avant la conversion
il a considéré tout comme perte
même comme des labous
lorsqu'il a connu véritablement
l'excellence de la connaissance du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
mon Seigneur
pour lequel j'ai rénoncé à tout.
Mais ces rénoncements qu'il a fait
ce n'était pas un rénoncement coûteux
pénible
bien sûr qu'il par la perspective humaine
ça lui a coûté tout
et par la perspective de sa propre discrétion
c'est comme s'il disait
un soleil glorieux s'est élevé
et tout est devenu opaque
tout est devenu sombre
comparativement à l'éclat du soleil
de la gloire du Christ.
C'était facile de rénoncer
toutes les étoiles de ma vie
car lorsque le soleil s'est élevé
les étoiles ont perdu leur brie.
Et donc il était
emparé d'une sainte obsession
où il a voulu
regarder tout comme des labous
afin de gagner Christ.
Donc il a vu Christ
il a contemplé Christ
Dieu lui-même
qui s'est incarné
pour vivre la vie parfaite
que personne n'arrive à vivre
pour mourir la croix
à cause de nos péchés
et qui nous donne accès
à la présence des dieux
mais qui nettoie aussi
la compréhension
et la connaissance des dieux
d'une manière très expérimentale
non seulement en train de révéler
toute la gloire et la beauté des dieux
dans la sainteté des dieux
mais particulièrement étant
lui-même Dieu fait chair
il démontre
de la manière la plus didatique
envers les êtres humains
la toute amabilité
des dieux lui-même
car on peut voir
Dieu comme si Dieu
vivait entre nous
et Dieu a vécu entre nous
en Christ
et donc Paul
il est emparé
de cet amour
de cette adoration
de cette passion pour Jésus
et il rénonce tout
car maintenant
à partir du moment
où il s'est converti
il a déjà goûté radicalement
la joie suprême
de sa vie
qui a rendu
tous les autres plaisirs
complètement trivial
mais à partir de là
c'est qu'il a goûté du Christ
même si c'était
la plus grande joie
de sa vie jusqu'ici
lui disait encore
cette source de joie
est infinie
les plus vous progressez
dans cette sainte obsession
de mieux connaître Christ
et de mieux comprendre
ce qu'il a fait pour vous
les plus vous serrez dans la joie
c'est impossible
de vous investir
dans la direction
de l'excellence
de la connaissance du Christ
et de vous frustrer
le seul schéma
d'agrandir une joie
qui est déjà la joie suprême
qu'on a goûté
c'est de nous approfondir
davantage
dans la compréhension
la connaissance
et l'amour des dieux
révélé en Christ
largeur
hauteur
profondeur
et Paul nous enseigne aussi
que c'est non seulement
par une espèce
de contemplation
du Christ
mais c'est
d'une manière très pratique
dans la vie
et donc au verset 10
et 11
il va dire
en dévenant
pardon
afin de connaître
Christ
et la puissance
de sa résurrection
et la communion
de ses souffrances
en dévenant conforme
à lui dans sa mort
pour parvenir
si je puis
à la résurrection
des morts
donc ce que Paul
est en train d'enseigner
c'est que nous pouvons
connaître Christ
de manière très positive
par la manière
dont il a
tout ce qu'il a fait
pour nous
de tout ce qu'il est
mais nous pouvons
connaître Christ
de manière
encore plus expérimentale
davantage
en cherchant
à imiter
sa vie
à fond
et particulièrement
imiter sa vie
en traversant
dans la direction
de la fidélité
de la promotion
de son roi homme
la souffrance
pour mieux comprendre
ce qu'il a supérieur
pour nous
pour nous conformer
davantage
à certaines joies
attention
que nous n'allons
jamais expérimenter
si nous ne traversons
pas ces parcours
comme on verra
au chapitre 4
il y a certaines promesses
qui sont plutôt
accrochées
à cette capacité
d'endurance
en fidélité
et en sainteté
par la souffrance
il y a
certains privilèges
que certains hommes
des dieux
ont vécu
que la majorité
des chrétiens
n'ont pas vécu
tout simplement
car la majorité
des chrétiens
n'ont pas persévéré
fidèles
en obéissance
malgré la souffrance
parce que Paul
va dire par exemple
au chapitre 4
qu'il devrait
se sanctifier
et les dieux
de la paix
sera avec vous
l'enseignement
c'est que
les plus
on progresse
dans l'obéissance
sous souffrance
en fidélité
pour faire promouvoir
son règne
les plus on expérimente
l'intimité
des dieux
et vers la fin
du chapitre 3
il dit
mais notre cité
à nous
est dans les cieux
vers ces vents
d'où nous attendons
aussi comme sauveurs
et seigneur Jésus Christ
qui transformera
les corps de notre humiliation
en les rendant semblables
au corps de sa gloire
par les pouvoirs
qu'il a d'assujettir
toutes les choses
donc Christ étant
les centres
de notre excellence
les retours du Christ
qui va signifier pour nous
la capacité suprême
de chérir les Christ
même si
pendant toute l'éternité
on va continuer
de progresser
dans notre capacité
de chérir les Christ
car Christ est
inépuisable
dans sa gloire
mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ici
il essaye
de tout rassembler
par rapport
à ce qui concerne
nos mieux espoirs
même pour ce qui concerne
cette vie
donc il va
transformer
notre corps
en corps glorifié
c'est à dire
nous n'allons plus
lutter
contre les maladies
ok
contre la vieillesse
contre ces douleurs
qui ne font qu'agrandir
après qu'on traverse
la moitié de la vie
et en même temps
ce corps sera glorifié
non seulement
dans ce qui concerne
son fonctionnement physique
mais aussi
on sera glorifié
pour ce qui concerne
la moralité
la spiritualité
la sanctification
et donc par là
on sera délivré
même
de ces déviations bêtes
qui nous avons encore
aujourd'hui
du lieu de nourrir
nos âmes
être tenté
à nourrir
tout simplement
les sensorielles
et avec une moralité
parfaite
notre palais
envers les choses
spirituelles
sera perfectionné
et voilà pourquoi
aussi nous allons
avoir une capacité
infiniment supérieure
de réjouir davantage
de la contemplation
du Christ
la glorification
de l'âme
mais
comme en bonus
on sera aussi
dans une gloire
où
l'univers
sera complètement
restauré
même la nature
qui est otage
de nos péchés
de notre rébellion
sera favorable
à nous
nous devrons plus
lutter
contre la nature
et la nature
contre nous
pour qu'on puisse
avoir les bonnes choses
de cette vie
et clairement
le centre
de tout ça
n'est pas
toutes les choses
qui vont davantage
maximiser notre plaisir
en Christ
c'est à dire
les bonnes choses
de cette vie
mais c'est de tout
réjouir avec Christ
et Christ
étant la compagnie
et la source
suprême
de notre joie
Paul est en train
d'exprimer
que cette cité
à nous
cette cité
est déjà
à nous
et elle est
dans les cieux
et nous attendons
pendant notre pèlerinage
le retour du Christ
mais c'est déjà
une réalité certaine
donc vu que nous sommes
déjà
les personnes
les plus riches
de la terre
qui ont
l'assurance
totale
que toutes ces réalités
nous surviendront
à cause
de la fidélité
du Christ
notre Seigneur
qui reviendra
chercher son épouse
son église
nous pouvons
nous détacher
de cette vie
et au lieu
d'attendre trop
que notre joie
se retrouve
dans les aspects
temporels
de cette vie
concentrer
toute notre attention
dans les sources
des joies
qui nous restent encore
et les sources
des joies
qui vont nourrir
particulièrement
notre nouvelle nature
vous êtes avec moi
et donc
les fondements
ultimes
de la joie
chrétienne
est cette espérance
inébranlable
dans les Seigneurs
ayant pour coeur
cette vision
béatifique
où Christ
reviendra
et par complément
la béatitude
éternelle
donc la joie
dans un monde
parfait
avec un corps
complètement
perfectionné
donc ça
c'est les fondements
naturels
si tout
va très mal
dans votre vie
et que vous
vous rappelez
de ça
et vous ancrez
votre joie
en soi
vous auriez
ici
la capacité
déjà
de vous réjouir
et donc
ayant ça
comme ancrage
de notre joie
suprême
nous pouvons
aussi
expérimenter
d'autres sources
des joies
dans notre pèlerinage
et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut
en ayant établi
ses fondements
son objectif
c'est un peu
la phrase de Jésus
envers les disciples
il a plu
à votre père céleste
de vous donner
son royaume
vendez vos biens
vos biens
et faites des aumones
c'est à dire
détachez-vous
de ces choses
et faites promouvoir
le royaume de Dieu
cherchez d'abord
son royaume
et sa justice
et toutes les autres
choses vous seront
rajoutées par dessus
et donc
il va démontrer
que la prison
n'a pas la capacité
de dérober
cette source des joies
et que cette source des joies
elle devient
de plus en plus
expérimentée
car on peut vivre
déjà
plusieurs anticipations
de la réalité
de ces royaumes
triomphants
car même Paul
en prison
va voir l'église
progresser
donc au chapitre 4
on est en train
de considérer
que Paul
va commencer
à appliquer
cette encre
dans une joie suprême
peut-être réjoui
par plusieurs sources
des joies
dans cette vie
et il présente
plusieurs aspects
au chapitre 4
le premier
c'est dans les seigneurs
et ça c'est une phrase
qui sera répétée
à chaque fois
pendant notre pèlerinage
nous avons pour source
des joies
l'amour fraternel
approfondie
par les services
dans les seigneurs
ça c'était la première réponse
on a déjà considéré
les versets 1 à 5
c'est-à-dire
l'église
une église
qui a été formée
par les efforts
de Paul
avec quelques compagnons
l'église
des philippiens
au verset 1
il dit
vous êtes ma joie
ma couronne
demeurez ainsi ferme
dans les seigneurs
donc c'est une église
qui était ferme
une église
qui prospérait
et lorsqu'il
Paul était en prison
c'était possible
que les frères
viennent vers lui
c'était plus facile
de trouver Paul
dans la prison
que de les trouver
en voyage
car il était
tous les temps
en voyage
et il a pu avoir
la joie vers la fin
de sa vie
vers la fin
de son ministère
de voir comment
cette église
continue de progresser
il reçoit des nouvelles
des personnes
qui sont chères
pour lui
il va citer des noms
il va penser au visage
il va penser
au témoignage
des conversions
de ces personnes
et combien ces personnes
ont servi
dans les ministères
avec lui
et il va même
avoir la possibilité
de contribuer davantage
à la fermeté
de cette église
qui n'est pas
une église parfaite
mais une église
qu'il était sûr
qu'avec un minimum
d'effort
de sa part
et la mobilisation
de certains frères
car il avait déjà vu
leur mieux
leur meilleur
même s'il y avait
quelque chose de moche
la division
entre
Évodie
et Senti
l'apôtre Paul dit
le minimum possible
et il est sûr
que ça va se régler
car
elles ont déjà
servi avec moi
été douces
l'une envers l'autre
et envers
ceux de dehors
et donc cette joie
et ces privilèges
d'avoir travaillé
au coeur
d'une vraie
famille des fois
étaient une source
de joie
non seulement
par
la perfection
de leur unité
mais l'évangile
de la réconciliation
que lorsque l'unité
n'est pas parfaite
on s'efforce ensemble
pour la restaurer
donc une source
de joie
pour nous tous
c'est la vie
des relations
significatives
au sein de l'église
des vraies relations
pas des relations
où les moindres
conflits
nous font
nous éloigner
les uns des autres
nous sommes unis
en Christ
et pour toujours
unis en Christ
nos noms sont
écrits dans les livres
de la vie
comme dit l'apôtre Paul
dans ces passages
comment dire
que nous ne pouvons pas
nous tolérer
si nous devons
vivre
toute l'éternité
ensemble
ensuite
notre source
de joie
c'est la prière
communautaire
versets 6 et 7
ne vous inquiétez
de rien
mais en toute chose
faites connaître
vos besoins à Dieu
par des prières
et des supplications
avec des actions
de grâce
et la paix
de Dieu
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
ça c'est un recours
que Paul avait
bien sûr
dans la prison
de manière individuelle
mais ici
c'est une espèce
d'encouragement
communautaire
envers l'église
de Philippe
plusieurs d'entre nous
ne sont pas en train
d'expérimenter la joie
car ils ne sont pas
en train de prier
comme il faut
mais à plusieurs reprises
ils sont en train
de négliger
les prières
communautaires
Dieu
il aime bien
répondre
à tous ses enfants
de manière particulière
il prend
une considération
chacun
de ses enfants
mais c'est clair
qu'il aime bien
traiter avec ses corps
unis
sa famille
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
ne vous inquiétez
de rien
donc à nouveau
un contraste
entre joie
et inquiétude
mais la solution
contre l'inquiétude
n'est pas de trouver
nos propres solutions
pour faire la bataille
contre un monde
qui n'aime pas
les chrétiens
dans un contexte
où
peu importe
si nous sommes chrétiens
ou non
nous sommes en train
de vivre
la chute
la difficulté
même pour mener
la vie
les maladies
touchent
juste et injuste
car nous sommes
tous pécheurs
des bases
et nous sommes
en train de vivre
la période
de la patience
de Dieu
et Dieu
peut par sa grâce
anticiper
certaines bénédictions
pour rendre
nos vies
plus simples
plus faciles
mais car les restes
de la chair
sont encore là
à plusieurs reprises
cela peut représenter
même un pillage
pour nous
et donc Dieu
dans sa grâce
il nous enseigne
qu'il est plus important
c'est de ne nous
jamais nous éloigner
de la présence
de Dieu tout puissant
qui est notre
Père céleste
et qui assure
qu'il est en train
de gouverner
chaque atome
de l'univers
en faveur de son église
d'ailleurs
ne ratez pas
la prochaine leçon
sur la providence
car ça c'est un point
qu'on va traiter
comment Dieu
est en train
de gouverner
chaque atome
de l'univers
en faveur
de son église
de la formation
de son peuple
de la sanctification
de l'intimité
de son peuple
avec lui
de la joie
de son peuple
tout simplement
et donc
les prières ici
passent par
les supplications
par lesquelles
on va
déposer
dans les mains
de notre Père céleste
tous nos désirs
c'est mieux
qu'il y ait besoin
tous nos désirs
certains désirs
ce n'est pas
ils ne peuvent
pas être
les mieux pour nous
et voilà pourquoi
Dieu ne va pas
nous donner des choses
qui peuvent nous faire mal
peut-être on n'est pas
encore prêts
à se voir
mais ça fait du bien
pour nous
de savoir qu'une fois
qu'on a déposé
dans les mains
de Dieu
notre Père
c'est à lui
dans sa sagesse
dans sa puissance
dans son amour
de décider
si c'est bon pour moi
ou non
quand c'est bon pour moi
et donc
j'enlève
la préoccupation
car la Bible
m'ençait
que Dieu
n'est pas un Dieu
contre moi
c'est un Dieu
à faveur de moi
et par cette intimité
par cette communion
par la prière
avec Dieu
les résultats
c'est le verset 7
la paix de Dieu
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
et c'est ça
qui est intéressant
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
donc ce que Paul
il vise à communiquer
c'est que
les résultats
les plus importants
de la prière
et surtout les prières
qui doivent toujours
compter avec
l'action des grâces
car on peut présenter
à Dieu
ce qu'on aimerait
avoir
ou les choses
qu'on aimerait
qui changent
mais il faut toujours
reconnaître
par action des grâces
que nous
ne sommes pas
en train de souffrir
à la hauteur
de ce dont on mérite
on a toujours
des raisons
pour être
dans la reconnaissance
et on a déjà
reçu Christ
et son esprit
et la certitude
et la promesse
future
donc on aura
toujours
des actions
des grâces
et la joie
est proportionnelle
à l'action des grâces
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
que cette paix
des dieux
qui surpasse
toute l'intelligence
pourquoi elle surpasse
pour plusieurs raisons
qu'on a déjà vues
mais l'une d'entre elles
qui est très importante
c'est de nous rappeler
que même
lorsque toutes les personnes
qui nous observent
de l'extérieur
n'arrivent pas
à rationnellement
comprendre
comment nous pouvons
avoir la joie
et la paix
surpasse toute l'intelligence
car Paul est
dans la prison
frappé
battu
abandonné
trahi
par plusieurs
de ses compagnons
et il est toujours
dans la joie
et dans la paix
comprenez
surpasse toute l'intelligence
mais c'est une paix
qui surpasse
toute l'intelligence
mais qui n'est pas
déraisonnable
elle surpasse
la raison
mais elle a
plusieurs raisons
et l'une d'entre elles
c'est de garder
nos pensées
et nos affections
à Jésus Christ
si par la prière
on est
de plus en plus
conscient
de la présence
du Christ
car nous prions
au nom du Christ
au Père
qui est dans son trône
des grâces
et Christ est devant
l'étrône de la grâce
quand on prie
on s'est jouant
à Christ
dans sa prière
pour nous
et on sait
qu'il n'y a
aucun empêchement
de la part de Dieu
pour nous bénir
donc nos circonstances
présentes
lorsqu'on prie
on est sûr
car la prière
est aussi un moyen
par lequel
Dieu aime bien agir
c'est comme dit Calvin
c'est son nommant
étendu
pour recevoir
toutes les bénédictions
que Dieu veut
déjà nous donner
donc la prière
est un moyen
à travers lequel
Dieu fait son œuvre
en nous
et si on accomplit
cette tâche
on peut se reposer
mais surtout
ça dévie
nos égards
des circonstances
qu'on pense
qui doivent changer
pour qu'on soit
dans la joie
ça dévie
nos égards
des choses
qu'on aimerait avoir
et qui sont en train
de nous accabler
car on n'en a pas encore
et elle met notre attention
et elle garde
nos cœurs
et nos pensées
en Jésus Christ
l'objet suprême
de notre joie
de notre paix
car c'est lui
qui a fait la paix
avec Dieu
en pourvoyant
la réconciliation
dans sa vie
dans son propre corps
dans son œuvre
vous comprenez comment
Christ
est le mieux remède
contre l'anquiétude
ou l'anxiété
donc plusieurs
traversent la dépression
l'anquiétude
l'anxiété
car leur cœur
et leurs pensées
ne sont pas en train
d'être gardés
en Christ
car ils ne sont
tout simplement
pas en train
de prier
et pas en train
en communauté
car certains
d'entre nous
lorsqu'on est
en train
de vivre
nos mieux
moments avec Dieu
d'autres d'entre nous
sont en train
de vivre
une sensation
d'éloignement
et par nos prières
communautaires
nos prières
les uns
par les autres
nous sommes
influencés
sous l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
par la ferveur
des certains
et donc
le troisième point
qu'on a commencé
à considérer
la semaine dernière
et que nous allons
continuer
de considérer
aujourd'hui
c'est la
sanctification
opérante
qui promeut
l'intimité
avec Dieu
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans les passages
du verset 8
le verset 8 et 9
mais même
cette fin
du verset
7 doit être considéré
donc quelque part
garder nos cœurs
et nos pensées
en Jésus Christ
et ensuite
lier à cette considération
ce que cela peut représenter
c'est
au reste
frère
qui est tout ce qui est vrai
lisez avec moi
verset 8
tout ce qui est honorable
tout ce qui est juste
tout ce qui est pur
tout ce qui est aimable
tout ce qui mérite
l'approbation
s'il y a quelques vertus
s'il y a quelques louanges
que cela occupe
vos pensées
c'est vous
ce qui vous avez appris
reçu
et entendu
de moi
et ce qui vous avez
vu en moi
pratiquez-le
et les dieux de la paix
seront avec vous
donc remarquez déjà
la promesse
pour qu'on soit accroché
et on va revenir
à la promesse
par
la prière
communautaire
persévérante
on reçoit
la paix
des dieux
par
l'obéissance
ou la sanctification
on constate
les dieux
des paix
vous êtes avec moi
c'est la promesse
la plus glorieuse
qu'on peut expérimenter
dans cette vie
des pèlerinages
et donc
il y a une relation
très claire
entre
la sanctification
et la joie
car
les versets
commencent
avec
un coeur
gardé
et les pensées
gardées
en Jésus Christ
les versets
passent
par
nous-mêmes
par nos réflexions
par nos pensées
nourrissant
une résolution
à mener
une vie
honorable
à tous égards
et il finit
avec une exhortation
très sévère
à la mise
en pratique
de ce qui ont dit
être nos affections
nos pensées
et nos résolutions
donc la sanctification
elle s'empare
de toutes les espères
de la vie humaine
si vous voulez
progresser
en santé
comme quelqu'un
a déjà dit
séparer du temps
pour être sans
et donc
dans une génération
qui a tellement
rebaissé
les paramètres
de la santé
et qui à plusieurs reprises
manque de repères
et qui parfois
fait plus de confiance
à ses propres stratégies
et voilà pourquoi
même les implications
de croire
à la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
elles sont importantes
car quand on pense
que les saluts
de personnes
ou la sanctification
dépendent
de nos stratégies
non je ne veux pas
être très dur
dans les exigences
sinon elle va
s'éloigner
de l'église
la réalité
c'est que
tous les êtres humains
ont une conscience
éveillée
devant dieu
et si nous travaillons
dans la direction
des dieux
envers les attentes
un jour
un ami à moi
qui n'est pas chrétien
me posait des questions
sur les thèmes
de l'homosexualité
et
j'avais mes questions
car ce n'était pas
lui-même pas une personne
qui pratiquait la chose
plus tard j'ai compris
pourquoi les questions
mais beaucoup de résistance
jusqu'au point
où il m'a demandé
mais
si jamais ça arrivait
dans ta famille
quelle serait ta procédure
est-ce que tu vas
abandonner ton enfant
j'ai expliqué
nous sommes tous
corrompus
pour ce qui concerne
la sexualité
ceux qui sont
plutôt hétérosexuels
dans leur résolution
des vies
souvent
ils vont lutter
contre la tentation
envers la dutère
ou la polygamie
la sexualité
est plus large
que la pratique sexuelle
nous sommes tous
certainement
très corrompus
pour ce qui concerne
notre rôle
dans la famille
dans la société
en tant que mari
en tant qu'homme
et les femmes aussi
par contre
les plus
on s'efforce
pour s'approcher
du paramètre
biblique
de ce qui Dieu
a constitué
comme un turc
car Dieu
est un Dieu bon
le plus on s'efforce
le plus
on s'est satisfait
et donc bien sûr
que mon amour
envers mon enfant
ne peut pas
permettre
que je les chasse
complètement
de ma vie
à cause
de son péché
et notamment
pour ce qui concerne
les non-chrétiens
encore plus
mais j'essaierai
toute ma vie
en train
à cause de zèle
pour son bien
pour sa joie
j'essaierai
pour toute ma vie
en train
de vouloir
les convaincre
que le mieux
pour lui
ne sera pas
trouvé
dans cette pratique
nous avons tous
besoin d'un sauveur
nous pouvons considérer
que certains
sont plus éloignés
que d'autres
réellement
des certains
paramètres bibliques
mais Dieu
nous a donné
un ordre
et la conscience
de tous les êtres
en train de vouloir
ont la capacité
de décodifier
le fait
que la sanctification
produit la joie
et que la réjouissance
des plaisirs
corrompus
est très éphémère
car elle sera
toujours mêlée
par la coupabilité
et dans un échange
un autre jour
j'ai célébré
un mariage
et les responsables
de la cérémonie
étaient homosexuels
et on a fait
un déjeuner ensemble
et lui
il a commencé
à ouvrir son cœur
envers moi
et il avait dit
qu'il avait essayé
quand même
de s'approcher
des églises
qu'il n'était jamais
en paix
avec cette pratique
mais c'était une force
des péchés
plus fort que lui
il a commencé
à ouvrir son cœur
j'ai essayé
de m'approcher
de l'église
mais les préjugements
et la porte fermée
étaient tellement
immédiates envers moi
que j'essayais
de manière privée
et je n'y arrivais pas
il n'a tout simplement
pas connu l'évangile
de manière expérimentale
comme il faut
mais cette
vérité
que la Bible
nous assure
les constats
que tous les êtres
ont car on ne peut
pas assumer
par exemple
que l'athée
est vraiment athée
car la Bible
nous enseigne clairement
que l'athéisme
est un refuge
est un recours
corrompu
de vouloir supprimer
l'idée de Dieu
et l'homosexualité
c'est la même chose
il y a une conscience
qui les accuse
contrairement à cette réalité
mais nous devons
savoir aussi
reconnaître
qu'il y a plusieurs reprises
certains
marchent
dans la direction
de l'homosexualité
pourquoi
car
les hommes
ont abusé
de leur rôle
d'autorité
ils ne sont pas
des hommes
comme il fallait
la réaction extrême
de féminisme
a inversé
complètement
les rôles
de la maison
et les enfants
sont élevés
sans répère
et nous sommes exposés
à ce type
de conséquences
donc il faut
que nous
en tant qu'église
on ait
une bonne dose
de générosité
pour savoir
reconnaître
que nous sommes
tous corrompus
mais jamais oubliés
que nous ne pouvons
jamais chercher
à prendre
une voie
où on essaye
d'alléger
les exigences publiques
de rebaisser
qu'on porte
qu'on soit
dans la génération
de la facile
accessibilité
à la pornographie
la Bible
elle est très claire
arrache ton oeil
tous les vrais
chrétiens
et tous les êtres
humains
savent
qu'ils ne doivent pas
mener leur relation
de cette manière
et au lieu
de dire
non on va
traiter légèrement
bien sûr
on ne peut jamais
attendre
de la part
des non-chrétiens
comportement chrétien
par contre
à partir du moment
où nous sommes
devenus chrétiens
si notre vie
est menée
de cette manière
comment occuper
nos pensées
qu'est-ce qui doit
occuper
notre temps
si nous ne séparons
pas du temps
pour être sains
si nous n'avons pas
de la diligence
pour nous scientifier
nous n'allons pas
trouver la sanctification
et nous n'allons pas
trouver la joie
car les personnes
les plus malheureuses
de l'univers
sont des personnes
qui sont des vraiment
chrétiens
qui ont donné
trop d'espace
à la chair
et qui vivent
dans les péchés
ils ont
mis les plaisirs
dans les mondes
avec leur vie
prégrès
dans les péchés
qu'ils avaient
avant la conversion
car désormais
il y a l'esprit
saint des dieux
qui est attristé
et qui éveille
davantage leur conscience
et des fois
ils se sentent
comme des hypocrites
car ils n'arrivent
pas à revenir
à l'église
car les diables
profitent
de cette phase
des péchés
pour leur dire
vous ne pouvez pas
y aller
car tu es un hypocrite
et donc
l'apôtre
il est en train
de dire ici
source
des joies
pour vous
embrasser
les difficultés
avec
sainteté
et donc
la sanctification
ici
dans les passages
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
elle engage
toutes les airs
de la vie humaine
et la paix
des dieux
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
donc la première partie
c'est la contemplation
là c'est
vraiment
de garder
nos yeux spirituels
nos méditations
lorsqu'on va lire
la Bible
de chercher
avant tout
à nourrir l'âme
de l'adoration
du Christ
les remèdes
les plus efficaces
envers la sanctification
la motivation
la plus efficace
envers la sanctification
c'est pas de démontrer
toutes les mauvaises conséquences
de tous les péchés
vous n'allez jamais finir
nous avons besoin
d'une motivation
qui est la capacité
comme dit l'apôtre Paul
l'excellence
de la connaissance du Christ
a fait que
tous les restes
soient de la boue pour moi
donc c'est
la contemplation
j'ai lu ma Bible
et mon intérêt
n'est pas de trouver
dans la Bible
la solution
pour mes problèmes actuels
en calant
envers mes désirs
idolâtres
quand j'ouvre ma Bible
l'objet principal
n'est pas moi
je veux voir la gloire
et la beauté du Christ
c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser
à chaque fois
qu'on ouvre la Bible
qu'est-ce que ce texte
me révèle à propos
de la beauté du Christ
et ça nourrit mon âme
donc les prières
sans réflexion
sans les pensées
sans la résolution
peuvent ne pas
aboutir à grandes choses
on ne peut pas
être tout simplement
en train de prier
et attendre que tout
change dans notre vie
il faut que nos
prières soient accompagnées
de cette contemplation
expérimentale du Christ
ce sont les prières
contemplatives
comme on dit
ou des lectures bibliques
qui nous conduisent
toujours à la prière
cette intimité
avec le Seigneur Jésus
c'est d'avoir nos yeux
spirituels fixés en Christ
comme dit Paul au Corinthien
2e Corinthien 15
amener toute pensée
captive à l'obéissance
de Christ
la motivation suprême
de l'obéissance
c'est de conformer
nos vies à Christ
et ici Christ
donc nous est présenté
comme les gardiens
de nos pensées
à nouveau
on ne peut pas
s'empêcher
que Satan
nous lance des flèches
pour qu'on ait
des mauvaises pensées
des pensées charnelles
on ne peut pas
toujours s'empêcher
mais on doit prier
que nos chemins
ne croisent pas
les chemins
de la tentation
délivrent-nous
du chemin
du malin
mais nous pouvons
nous empêcher
de demeurer
dans ces pensées
dans ces tentations
dans ces affections
j'ai mal gardé
mon coeur
j'ai permis
que mes affections
comme la passion
d'un adolescent
s'élance
envers
une personne
qui n'est pas
croyante
je dois
couper
et soupler
Christ
garde
mes affections
car développer
cette relation
représente
d'éloigner
ma relation
avec Christ
Christ
le gardien
de nos pensées
Christ le gardien
de nos affections
et lorsque
l'inquiétude
frappe à la porte
ou lorsque
la tentation
frappe à la porte
on va demander
à Christ
d'ouvrir
car nos pensées
et nos affections
sont imprégnées
du Seigneur
Jésus Christ
donc Christ
les remède ultime
donc il y a cet aspect
des contemplations
le premier aspect
le deuxième aspect
qui est aussi lié à ça
c'est d'être
plus catégorique
dans ce qui représente
avoir nos pensées
imprégnées du Christ
c'est-à-dire
ok
Christ l'objet
de mon adoration
mais aussi Christ
le modèle de ma vie
devant cette situation
devant cette circonstance
quelle décision prendre
quelle est la voie
car la vie
glorieuse du Christ
en termes de sanctification
a été vécue
ici-bas
et donc
le deuxième
le deuxième aspect
c'est l'aspect
de la méditation
de la raison
de la résolution
de la stratégie sainte
que cela
occupe vos pensées
qu'est-ce qui doit
occuper mes pensées
donc c'est Christ
qui doit occuper mes pensées
mais Christ
maintenant
vit
très pratique
et donc
les lieux de la raison
est fondamental
dans le christianisme
la tristesse
l'inquiétude
les égarments
les rechutes
les oscillations
dans la vie du chrétien
sont liées
à plusieurs reprises
au manque
des raisonnements
on veut tout régler
par les sentiments
par l'expérience
spirituelle
tout régler
par la contemplation
mais la personne
n'est jamais assise
pour mettre
dans un papier
toutes les possibilités
qu'il a aujourd'hui
en termes de décision
pour faire
une hiérarchie
de ses buts
et se demander
si cette hiérarchie
est conforme
à la Bible
et quelle option
va plus honorer
louer
glorifier Dieu
quelle option
représenterait
le plus
la manière dont Christ
organiserait
ma vie
des fois
la vie nous frappe
et dans une réaction
désespérée
très émotionnelle
on prend des décisions
précipitées
et on se compromet
dans notre témoignage
la raison
elle est fondamentale
l'évangile
est toujours plus
que la raison
mais jamais moins
l'efficacité
pour la conversion
à plusieurs reprises
manque
d'une explication
raisonnable
de l'évangile
Jésus
t'aime
n'est pas
un moyen
d'évangéliser
c'est un moyen
très émotionnel
émotionnaliste
plutôt
mais si je
n'explique pas
qui est Christ
Dieu homme
et ce qu'il a fait
pour manifester
son amour
pour moi
Dieu a tant aimé
le monde
qu'il a donné
son fils
unique
pour que
tous ceux
qui croient
en lui
ne périssent pas
mais aient la vie éternelle
donc si je ne donne pas
les raisons
qui conduisent
la personne
à la conversion
personne ne s'est converti
par une relation
émotionnaliste
avec Christ
pour la sanctification
c'est la même chose
tu connais
les lettres sacrées
qui font
sages
pour la vérité
pour les saluts
pardon
à salut
toute écriture
est inspirée
les dieux
utile pour
instruction
correction
dans la justice
pour que l'homme
des dieux
soit
parfait
et parfaitement
habilité
à toute bonne oeuvre
qu'est-ce que l'apôtre
répond
en train de dire
quand il dit
de préserver
la doctrine
la saine doctrine
c'est car la
sanctification
est liée
au raisonnement
à l'étude
diligent
de la parole
des dieux
parfois on est en train
de se battre
contre un péché
qui est par la prière
par la contemplation
en attendant
que la sainteté
tombe
du ciel
la prière
est nécessaire
mais il faut aussi
trouver dans la bible
les raisons
qui nous mènent
à la sanctification
et ce raisonnement
bien sûr
est un raisonnement
car les mots ici
quand il dit
que cela occupe
vos pensées
c'est à voir
avec la notion
pratique
de la pensée
c'est
à l'éminence
d'agir
vous êtes avec moi
c'est la résolution
comme les résolutions
des fins d'année
c'est la détermination
à plusieurs reprises
Satan
nous lance des doutes
nous lance des tentations
des découragements
comme disait Luther
un jour
il a dit
qu'il a eu un rêve
et qu'il s'est rêvé
au milieu de l'année
il a l'impression
que Satan
est là de son côté
et que Satan
c'est comme s'il suggérait
voici une liste
que j'ai préparée
avec tous les péchés
qui t'as commis
dernièrement
et lui
il était tellement
sage
ses pensées
étaient tellement
occupées de l'évangile
qu'il répond
t'as oublié aussi
celui-ci
celui-là
mais Christ
à la croix
a déjà payé
pour tous
quelles sont
les raisons
de notre espoir
pour défendre
la foi
contre les hérésies
lorsque Paul
va nous appeler
à consacrer
nos vies
de manière
sacrificielle
envers
la sanctification
roman 12
il va dire
je vous exhorte
par les miséricordes
de Dieu
de présenter vos corps
comme sacrifice
vivant à Dieu
c'est qu'il y avait
de votre part
quoi ?
un culte
raisonnable
jusqu'au chapitre 11
toutes les raisons
montent pour qu'on
s'essentifie
à partir de là
c'est raisonnable
que vous sacrifiez
vos vies
au service
et à la sainteté
lorsque Jésus
va faire son serment
contre l'anxiété
et les inquiétudes
en Matthieu 6
il va donner
des raisons
pour lesquelles
on ne doit pas
s'inquiéter
votre père céleste
connaît
tout ce dont vous avez besoin
un rhum même
qui vous l'a dit
cherchez d'abord
les rhum
déduire sa justice
et toutes les autres choses
vous seront rajoutées
par dessus
et donc lorsqu'on est
devant
la tentation
de l'anxiété
on crie
envers nous même
envers nos âmes
et on se dit
quoi ?
moi ?
un enfant de Dieu
tout puissant
me permet de paralyser
être terrifié
ponique
quoi ?
moi ?
un enfant de Dieu ?
un Dieu qui gouverne
chaque molécule
à ma faveur ?
qui a compté
chaque fils
des cheveux
que j'ai ?
c'est de répondre
à la tentation
avec des raisons
bibliques
c'est comme
Jésus a résisté
à Satan
donc il y a
ces résolutions
on a déjà considéré
chacune de ces vertus
et de quelle manière
de manière pratique
on doit y aller
donc on doit être résolu
envers l'obéissance
déterminé
planifier
une démarche sainte
faire comme
David
obsomme 1
il va
méditer
la parole de Dieu
jour et nuit
bien sûr qu'il y a
quelques repères
dans la journée
avant de sortir
de la maison
peut-être à son retour
mais pendant
toute la journée
il va méditer
il va réfléchir
il va avoir
pour obsession
dans toutes les occasions
qu'il a dans la journée
de mettre en pratique
ce qu'il a médité
et quelles sont
les implications
dans ces psaumes ?
il ne va pas s'asseoir
par exemple
avec
les méchants
ceux qui méprisent
les justes
et donc c'est des savoirs
dans la vie pratique
qu'elle va éviter
et qu'elle va suivre
fondée sur la raison
imprégnée
de la parole de Dieu
et à la fin des comptes
c'est de nous demander
par tous ces termes-là
tout ce qui est vrai
tout ce qui est honorable
tout ce qui est juste
et d'établir des critères
pour savoir identifier
quelle est la voie
que Dieu a établie
devant moi
si cette voie
n'est pas intègre
vis-à-vis à ses vertus
ce n'est pas
la voie
que Christ a ouvert
par la manière
dont il a marché
dans ces mondes
ce n'est pas
une voie
pourvue
par Dieu
pour ma vie
donc c'est une voie
inexistante
pour moi
si c'est déshonorable
si c'est impur
si c'est injuste
ce n'est pas
une voie existante
pour moi
et on va faire
comme David
dans son psaume
il dit
Dieu a ouvert
un chemin
sous mes pieds
des fois on ne voit
même pas
c'est Moïse
devant la mer
ferbée
et l'armée
des pharaons
contre lui
il n'y a pas
de sortie
mais Dieu
pour honorer
mon intégrité
qui lui-même
a pourvu
par sa grâce
il ouvrera
un chemin
et donc c'est une question
de décider
envers l'obéissance
et les derniers aspects
les derniers aspects
que j'aimerais
considérer aujourd'hui
c'est les versets 9
qui est tellement riche
où l'apôtre Paul
il va dire
l'enseignement ici
c'est qui
la sanctification
n'est pas complète
sans l'action
même
les morts
qui ont été ressuscités
par Christ
ont dû
obéir
quelque part
à un commandement
impossible
Lazare
vient dehors
la puissance
est là
en forme
d'habilitation
mais c'est comme
si la foi
de Lazare
était exprimée
par l'obéissance
et il est ressuscité
lève-toi
et marche
paralytique
toute sa vie
comment on peut
se lever
car la puissance
qui habilite
elle commande
et par l'obéissance
nous allons constater
la puissance
qui Dieu a libérée
dans nos vies
à plusieurs reprises
ce qui manque
chez les chrétiens
c'est tout simplement
d'agir
de décider
de manière sainte
d'oser
obéir
car on ne constate
par la puissance
scientificatrice
des dieux
si on ne marche
pas en
sanctification
c'est comme
Lloyd-Jones
a dit une fois
il était dans
une conférence
sur les calvinistes
mais il était
étonné
de la capacité
de ces calvinistes
de faire
tellement de conférences
sans aucune
implication pratique
dans leur milieu
ils étaient dans
la contemplation
des grandes doctrines
et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui
on voit même
plus des divisions
provoquées
par des doctrines
que les progrès
dans la foi
comme dit l'apôtre Paul
et donc
Lloyd-Jones
dit ok
ici je suis devant
la théologie
calviniste
mais je ne suis pas
devant l'esprit
calviniste
car si la vérité
qui est comprise
par la raison
ne s'empare pas
des affections
et ne déborde pas
en action
la sanctification
n'a pas été aboutie
donc contempler
c'est super
réfléchir
et méditer
c'est super
mais à un moment donné
il faut
prendre une action
il faut agir
il faut marcher
Jacques nous dit
mettez en pratique
la parole
et ne vous bournez
pas
de l'écouter
en vous séduisant
vous-même
par des faux raisonnements
un raisonnement
qui n'aboutit pas
dans l'obéissance pratique
c'est un faux raisonnement
il peut être
théologiquement correct
mais s'il ne change pas
la vie pratique
c'est un faux raisonnement
au verset 25
il dit
mais c'est lui
qui aura plongé
les égards
dans la loi parfaite
la parole des dieux
la loi de la liberté
donc c'est volontaire
qui en obéit
et qui aura persévéré
n'étant pas
un auditeur
oublieux
mais en mettant
à l'oeuvre
celui-là
sera heureux
dans son activité
d'où vient
la joie chrétienne
et la pratique
de la sanctification
et c'est intéressant
car
Paul va
il va faire
une déclaration
ici
que si
nous l'avions écouté
dans notre génération
ça allait
contre
toutes les valeurs
post-modernes
qu'on puisse imaginer
la post-modernité
elle a une représentation
d'insoumission
à toute autorité
qui a reçu
en vernis
des louanges
avec l'expression
autonomie
auto-loi
mes propres lois
on s'approche
dans le contexte
des prédications
et on voit
l'impact
encore aujourd'hui
car dans certains
poupitres
les personnes
elles sont en train
de prêcher
comme s'ils étaient
en train de donner
des suggestions
dans l'espoir
que les personnes
qui ont leur propre loi
jugent ce que
les prédicateurs parlent
donc c'est pas la Bible
qui a l'autorité suprême
et un prédicateur fidèle
à la Bible bien sûr
qui communique
l'autorité de Dieu
non c'est
moi je vais juger
ce que c'est homme
en train de dire
moi je juge la parole
je juge ces ministères
et on voit
comment ça a un impact
à la manière dont
les prédicateurs
de nos jours prêchent
si vous voulez
me joindre
maintenant
je vous invite
mais si vous voulez
vous fermez vos yeux
on va prier
la Bible nous ordonne
en tant que chrétien
de prier
fermez vos yeux
on va prier
c'est pas mon autorité
à moi
c'est l'autorité des dieux
et c'est comme ça
qu'on va faire
vous comprenez
direction claire
à partir des écritures
et donc aujourd'hui
il a cette phase
où si jamais
on entend quelqu'un dire
ce que vous avez appris
des mois
reçu des mois
entendu des mois
ce que vous avez vu en moi
pratiquez-le
on a l'impression
qu'il peut être
en train de s'émettre
à la position
de celui
qui doit être imité
par contre
c'est une attente
des dieux
envers tous les chrétiens
car c'est une puissance
qui n'est pas nôtre
qui pourvoit
une capacité
qui est accessible
et efficace
et nous voici
de manière très timide
dans une génération
qui aime bien
mettre beaucoup plus
d'emphase
dans nos faiblesses
qui est dans la puissance
des dieux
qui est déjà dans nos vies
la quantité de pasteurs
dans les dernières années
qui je vais être franc
c'est clair
que la vocation pastorale
elle a beaucoup
des challenges
et des difficultés
et plusieurs
peuvent se fatiguer
et avoir un burn out
mais lorsqu'on va
entendre
certains témoignages
c'est comme
s'ils n'avaient pas compris
que la Bible
nous appelle
à porter une croix
c'est un zèle
envers les bien-être
les conforts
où les personnes
ont
ont très peu
de capacité
de manifester
cette foi
qui est marquée
par les renoncements
et les sacrifices
et l'endurance
et la vulnérabilité
dépendre
de la provision
des dieux
et on dit
je pense que
je n'ai pas encore
de maturité
pour occuper
les pupitres
ok
Moïse aussi
il avait la même impression
et c'est important
de savoir
je suis un homme
des lèvres impures
et j'habite au milieu
d'un peuple
des lèvres impures
par contre
Dieu
nous a promis
sa sanctification
il a pourvu
et c'est lui
qui a promis
qu'il allait corroborer
un ministère fidèle
et donc
on reste toujours
dans la reconnaissance
de nos faiblesses
de notre pécheresse
de notre dépendance
constante
de la grâce
de Dieu
et ça ne s'applique
pas qu'au pasteur
ça s'applique
aux hommes
des familles
aux femmes
au sein de la famille
envers tous
ceux qui ont attend
de nous
dans notre vocation
mais si Dieu
nous a placés
dans ces postes
c'est à nous
d'assumer les rôles
de nous sentir
jamais prêts
mais toujours là
et pourquoi
Paul
il peut
les dire
c'est car
il réclame
une conduite
de vie fondée
sur son propre modèle
car de la même manière
qu'il est en train
d'imiter les crises
il appelle
les personnes à l'imiter
car nous avons besoin
des repères
ça c'est très important
et surtout
dans une génération
où les repères
nous manquent énormément
où nous vivons
les restes
d'une église
qui a été
tellement battue
frappée
corrompue
diluée
qui nous sont
tellement éloignés
des paramètres
bibliques
donc on doit revenir
et contempler
les seuls paramètres
pour les christianismes
que nous avons
sûr et certain
se trouvent
dans le Nouveau Testament
et là
nous ne trouvons pas
des bases
pour la superficialité
que nous voyons
d'une manière générale
bien sûr qu'il y aura
toujours des hommes fidèles
en toute génération
mais nous ne devons pas
penser
que c'est comme ça
que c'est
la vie chrétienne
car toutes les églises
vivent comme ça
ou c'est ça
un ministère
du pasteur
car toutes les églises
aujourd'hui
les pratiquent
comme ça
on doit chercher
à trouver
dans les pages
du Nouveau Testament
et nous trouvons
un homme
comme l'apôtre Paul
qui frappe
dans sa patrine
pour les biens
de cette église
car il va bientôt
délaisser ses montres
ce qui vous avez appris
reçu
entendu de moi
ce qui vous avez vu
en moi
pratiquez-le
les fonctionnements
humains
va avec cette vérité
car si
en soi-disant prophète
est ici très directive
et qu'il vous ordonne
beaucoup de choses
mais qu'il ne vous donne
pas accès
à sa vie
c'est pas de la nature humaine
de donner l'écoute
à des exigences
qui ne sont pas vérifiables
c'est très faible
de ne pas avoir
des repères si forts
et ça c'est rien non plus
d'avoir des personnes
qui peuvent donner
beaucoup d'exhortations
sans qu'on puisse vérifier
la manière dont ils vivent
donc Paul
il savait
à qui il était
en train d'adresser
et il savait
que ces personnes
avaient déjà constaté
son intégrité
et c'est de l'être humain
de se laisser influencer
et d'accepter
les exhortations
et l'enseignement
de quelqu'un
qui vit ce qu'il prêche
l'apôtre Paul dit
il prêche l'évangile
mais ni la puissance
de l'évangile
ils sont les ennemis
de la croix
ils ne sont pas prédisposés
à souffrir
ce qu'il faut
par contre
l'apôtre Paul
il a cette symétrie
car à plusieurs reprises
il va faire
recours
à sa propre biographie
pas pour se vanter
car à chaque fois
il va dire
par exemple
j'étais le dernier
apôtre à être appelé
mais il va dire
au verset 10
au premier corinthian
verset 9 pardon
car je suis
les membres des apôtres
je ne suis pas digne
d'être appelé apôtre
parce que j'ai persécuté
l'église
par la grâce
de Dieu
je suis ce que je suis
et sa grâce
envers moi
n'a pas été vaine
loin de là
j'ai travaillé
plus que tous
non pas moi
toutefois
mais la grâce
de Dieu
qui est avec moi
ainsi donc
que ce soit moi
que ce soit eux
voilà ce que nous prêchons
ce que vous avez cru
donc
il faut remarquer
l'apôtre Paul
n'est pas en train
de donner son exemple
pour dire
imiter tout simplement moi
imiter moi
pratiquer ce que vous avez vu
en moi
car je suis un imitateur
du Christ
et c'est la grâce
de Dieu
qui a fait de moi
ce que je suis
et là
Paul va
pointer
envers
ces facettes
de son ministère
qui deviennent
quelque part
pour nous tous
des préconditions
nous allons rendre compte
si jamais
Dieu nous a donné
la grâce
d'avoir entre nous
des hommes fidèles
qui ont incarné
l'évangile
en qui nous avons
pu identifier
Christ
avec ces privilèges
vient une responsabilité
car ça dépasse
la relation
entre l'apôtre Paul
et les philippiens
c'est Dieu
qui par sa grâce
a donné
ces cadeaux
de la présence
d'apôtre Paul
entre les philippiens
et c'est les paramètres
quelque part
les plus proches
de l'approximation
du Christ
qu'ils avaient
dans ces contextes
et c'est
les christianismes
qu'ils devraient pratiquer
donc ils disent
ce que vous avez
appris de moi
c'est à dire
la priorité
de l'enseignement
biblique
les ailes d'épaule
à présenter toujours
un évangile
fidèle à la parole
dont la moindre déviation
est anathème
donc sa tâche primaire
c'est ce que Paul
a enseigné à cette église
ensuite il dit
et ce que vous avez
reçu
de moi
et là
ces termes
il a l'époix
d'oracle divin
c'est à dire
c'était pas tout simplement
un homme
qui présentait un diapo
avec des théologies
correctes
et co-communiquées
rien de grave
avec les diapos
que ça soit clair
mais
c'était pas
tout simplement
un transfert
professoral
d'information
c'était un homme
des dieux
que lorsqu'il enseignait
les personnes
avaient la capacité
d'attester
que l'onction
des dieux
était sur lui
et comme
les pharisiens
devant l'écrivain
disaient
ils prêchent
comme quelqu'un
qui a l'autorité
et pas comme
les pharisiens
pas avec
beaucoup d'excuses
ou beaucoup de sagesse
selon la rhétorique humaine
beaucoup de déviations
et l'apôtre Paul
il prêchait
de manière
que les personnes
avaient la sensation
Dieu m'est pas
à travers
la bouche
de cet homme
c'est que vous avez
reçu de moi
c'est pas l'impression
que quelque chose
vient de lui-même
mais reçu
de Dieu
à travers lui
et même si
c'était pour
plutôt pour confirmer
de manière littérale
l'autorité apostolique
de l'apôtre Paul
tous ceux
qui s'accrochent
à l'enseignement
apostolique
dans la dépendance
du Saint-Esprit
en prière
vivent encore
aujourd'hui
les prédicateurs fidèles
l'expérience
de compter
avec l'onction
du Saint-Esprit
lorsqu'ils prêchent
fidèlement
l'enseignement
des apôtres
on n'a plus d'apôtres
mais basé
sur l'enseignement
apostolique
nous avons encore
cette sensation
de recevoir
quelque chose
des dieux
à travers ces hommes
c'est qu'ils vous avaient
entendu
des mois
donc c'est qu'ils ont
reçu l'apôtre Paul
allait au-delà
de ce qu'il parlait
la Bible
met beaucoup d'emphase
sur le fait
que c'est lui
qui porte l'enseignement
à proximité
c'est Paul
qui est en train
d'écrire
je suis déjà
presque en train
d'être livré
comme libation
ma fidélité
à cet enseignement
m'a mis en prison
et toutefois
l'évangile
n'arrête de grandir
dans le monde entier
donc vous êtes
décroché
de ma présence physique
par contre
vous allez
accompagner
mon témoignage
jusqu'à la mort
vous avez
contemplé
mon endurance
la manière
dont j'ai défendu
l'évangile
dans mes jugements
plusieurs m'ont
abandonné
mais Christ
était avec moi
pour me donner
les supports
dont j'avais besoin
pour que l'évangile
soit proclamé
aux païens
donc vous êtes
encore en train
d'entendre
à propos de moi
et vous avez vu
que les souffrances
du Christ
ne m'éloignent pas
de ma vocation
je continue
je persévère
dans mon intégrité
et c'est
ce que vous avez
vu en moi
donc
vous êtes en train
d'entendre
la continuité
dans l'historique
dont vous avez
pu vous-même
attester
lorsque j'étais
entre vous
un homme
qui incarnait
la présence
du Christ
entre ces peuples
quelque chose
de surnaturel
qui
la simple communion
et l'observation
de la vie
de cet homme
nous poussait
et nous inspirait
à l'imitation
du Christ
et nous inspirait
à la sanctification
c'était une espèce
de puissance
dans la vie
de l'apôtre Paul
qui réjouissait
je me rappelle
très bien
mon privilège
d'avoir eu
un homme des dieux
un prédicateur
très puissant
l'onction
de son esprit
constante
et l'essence
des privilèges
que j'avais
quand j'avais
la moindre opportunité
d'avoir des conversations
avec lui
et plus récemment
aujourd'hui
bien sûr
pour Achère
qu'il y a un grand
repère pour nous
d'intégrité
de fidélité
et passer du temps
avec lui
et connaître
tous ses renoncements
toutes les souffrances
qu'il traverse
pour faire
l'évangile progresser
quel sens
de joie
de privilège
une source
de joie
avoir des tels
hommes
entre nous
qui inspirent
la sanctification
qui nous réjouit
à la fois
donc c'est très important
quand on regarde la Bible
avoir des repères
l'apôtre Paul lui-même
aux Philippiens
il a parlé
d'autres hommes
qui doivent imiter
et honorer
des tels hommes
qui vous ayez
recevés donc
dans les seigneurs
avec une joie entière
et honorée
des tels hommes
car c'est pour l'œuvre
du Christ
qu'il a été près
de la mort
en parlant
des paphrodites
ensuite il dit
au verset 17
chapitre 3
soyez mes imitateurs
frères
et portez les regards
sur ce qui marche
selon les modèles
que vous avez vus
en nous
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
l'importance
des repères
dans nos vies
et surtout
quand on médite
à propos de la fête
des mères
car Paul va écrire
à Timothée
et il a une grande assurance
dans l'épanouissement
de sa foi
car
il savait
de qui
il avait appris
alors tous ceux
qui veulent vivre
pieusement en Christ
Jésus
seront persécutés
mais les hommes méchants
et imposteurs
avanceront toujours
plus dans les mâles
s'égarant les autres
et égarer eux-mêmes
toi demeure dans les choses
que tu as prises
et reconnue comme certaines
sachant de qui
tu les as apprises
dès ton enfance
tu connais
les simples lettres
qui peuvent te rendre
sage à salut
à la fois
en Jésus Christ
dans d'autres passages
il va mentionner
qu'il a appris
de sa mère
et de sa grande mère
donc
le premier modèle
pour nos enfants
c'est la foi
et quel témoignage
on donne
est-ce que notre vie
des sanctifications
car comment nos enfants
vont donner l'écoute
aux prédications
à l'église
à la parole de Dieu
si leurs premiers
les premiers repères
ne sont pas en train
de vivre en cohérence
et en conformité
avec ce qu'ils disent
être la parole de Dieu
et Dieu dans sa grâce
peut surmonter
nos imperfections
car ils seront aussi
rélevables devant Dieu
mais quel privilège
lorsqu'on a
la possibilité
de contempler
dans nos foyers
des mères
ou des pères
qui vivent l'évangile
en tant que repères
qui donnent
de manière très claire
la direction
vers cette vie
comme envie
des pèlerinages
donc les ambitions
sont la sanctification
et la promotion
du roi de Dieu
toutes les vocations
sont légitimes
et sont nécessaires
car elles sont
toutes des terrains
missionnaires
pour la promotion
de l'évangile
et c'est clair
qu'on devrait
évaluer
si nous sommes déjà
en train de construire
dans la pensée
et dans les futurs
dans les plannings
dans les prières
envers nos enfants
une estime
qui chérit
des hommes de Dieu
des repères
est-ce que j'ai prié
et j'essaye d'aspirer
et enseigner mon enfant
à aspirer
une vie
de consacration totale
à l'évangile
ou à mes filles
de désirer
de prier
de se préparer
pour être
une aide
pour un homme de Dieu
qui va se consacrer
à ton plan
pour le ministère
ou est-ce que
la manière
dont je suis en train
d'éduquer mes enfants
sont plutôt fixées
sur les biens temporels
de cette vie
donc l'ambition
suprême
des chrétiens
n'est pas tant
de prier
pour avoir
les privilèges
d'avoir des bons repères
mais c'est réjouir
dans les bons repères
qu'on a
mais c'est de devenir
repères
pour l'écrit
1ère Thessaloniciens
chapitre 1
verset 4 à 10
il va dire
sachant frère
bien aimé
des dieux
votre élection
parce que notre évangile
ne nous a pas été annoncé
seulement en parole
mais avec puissance
avec le Saint-Esprit
et avec une pleine certitude
ainsi que vous le savez
de quelle manière
nous
nous sommes conduits
parmi vous
pour votre bien
vous êtes devenus
attention
nos imitateurs
et ceux du Seigneur
ayant reçu la parole
dans une grande affliction
avec la joie
du Saint-Esprit
de sorte
que vous êtes devenus
un modèle
pour tous les croyants
de la Macédoine
et de l'Acaï
vous voyez
on doit aspirer
sous les dieux
donne-nous plus
des hommes des dieux
des dirigeants d'église
comme l'apôtre Paul
des personnes
qu'on puisse regarder
et chercher à apprendre
comment pratiquer
la vie chrétienne
comment prendre des décisions
dans la direction
de la volonté des dieux
Seigneur
donne-nous plus d'hommes
comme ça
des hommes des familles
qui conduisent
leur famille
de manière biblique
donc l'homme
fonctionne comme
un homme biblique
la femme comme
une femme biblique
et la famille ordonnée
c'était mon désir
car j'ai pas eu
une repère des pères
quand je me suis converti
et mon ambition
était
de marcher
avec les plus âgés
de la communauté
les pères
plus expérimentés
et d'apprendre
comment conduire
une famille
donne-nous ces repères
Seigneur
mais l'ambition
des chrétiens
c'est pas tout simplement
d'entendre des dieux
je vous ai donné
de mon repère
et d'entendre des dieux
maintenant
vous êtes les repères
pour cette génération
nous n'allons pas
nous baser
tout simplement
sauf si
les églises
envers lesquelles
nous lançons nos égards
sont plus matures
que nous
dans ces sens là
s'ils sont plus similaires
à Christ
à l'apôtre Paul
au Nouveau Testament
et là nous allons
nous inspirer
de ces églises
et chercher à les imiter
mais nous ne devons pas
regarder
les aspects faibles
de l'église
dans nos jours
pour chercher
des repères
pour nous
pour nous dire
bon
on peut rester
dans les médiocres
nous devons
être des repères
pour notre génération
et quels sont les résultats
pour finir
c'est que si
nous mettons en pratique
ces choses
les dieux
de la paix
sera avec nous
je parlais
étant de vous présenter
tous les passages bibliques
on peut penser à Daniel
on peut penser à Joseph
on peut penser à Moïse
lorsqu'il souffrait
pour faire avancer
les rames des dieux
combien de fois
ils ont expérimenté
la présence des dieux
avec eux
mais la vie
de l'apôtre Paul
il est en train de parler
de ce qu'il connaît
à combien de reprises
en prison
c'est le Seigneur lui-même
qui s'émet à son côté
et qui les fortifie
si nous voulons expérimenter
plus
le Seigneur Jésus lui-même
il a dit
ceux qui ont mes commandements
avec les gardes
ce sont ceux qui m'aiment
et ceux qui m'aiment
sera aimé de mon père
et je l'aimerai
et je me ferai connaître
à lui
c'est une promesse
palpable
littérale
plus d'expérience
avec l'intimité
des dieux
pendent dans notre pèlerinage
si l'église
elle veut véritablement
réjouir de la plus grande promesse
par la prière
la paix des dieux
par l'obéissance
sacrificielle
envers l'évangélisation
qu'est-ce qu'on va voir
la présence des dieux
avec nous
et j'essaierai avec vous
dès aujourd'hui
jusqu'à
consommation du monde
et j'essaierai avec vous
la présence des dieux
des dieux
!